we've all heard of the 12 days of
christmas but what about
12 words of christmas
here's the story behind a few of them 1.
xmas
xmas has been contentious over the years
with some arguing it's a term designed
to remove the religious
importance of christmas in fact x is the
symbol for chi
the first letter in the greek word for
christ and that is why christmas
or christ's mass became xmas
2. santa santa claus comes from the
dutch sinterklaas
which literally translates as saint
nicholas before saint nicholas was even
born though
the norse god odin was believed to lead
a hunting party through the sky
during yule and he even delivered
presents to children
3. carol coming from the latin karula
meaning circular dance carols used to be
pagan songs
sung all throughout the year they were
swiftly adopted by the romans and then
by the church as they were so popular
4. bauble this used to be the term for a
baton carried by court jesters or bauble
bearers in tudor england
back in the 17th century to give the
bauble to someone
actually meant to make fun of them 5.
tinsel coming from france etienne
edincelle meaning
sparkle or spark it became part of our
christmas tree decorations
thanks to a ukrainian fairy tale all
about a generous spider
who took pity on a poor family choosing
to spend the night
decorating their tree with a web of gold
and silver
six stockings originating from an old
english word
stock meaning trunk of a tree our
christmas stockings also have their own
christmas tale behind them
in it saint nicholas wanted to help a
poor man and his daughters
knowing they wouldn't accept charity he
threw three golden balls through their
window at night
each one landing in a different stocking
the balls were sometimes represented as
oranges which is why we get oranges in
our stockings
today seven chestnuts we can trace the
word chestnut back to castanea which
means nut from castana
a town in greece from here our chestnut
trees were imported to the rest of
europe
roman soldiers used to roast them over
an open fire or eat porridge out of them
before they went into battle eight
nativity
the word nativity comes from the latin
word nativist meaning born
it's thought the first nativity scene
was created by saint francis of assisi
in 1223 mary and joseph are usually
placed on either side of the manger
then you have the shepherds and don't
forget the three kings
they're traditionally added last 9.
reindeer santa's reindeer technically
come from new york and a poem called a
visit from saint nicholas
rudolph is also american first appearing
in a series of colouring books promoting
the christmas goods
of a department store his red nose was
nearly removed as the store manager was
concerned
there'd be links drawn between it and
heavy drinking
10. mistletoe the latter half of
mistletoe evolved out of tan
meaning twig the missile part was
another word for
dung bird done to be exact named as it
is because mistletoe sprouted out of
trees
wherever birds congregated kissing under
the bird poo
twig doesn't really sound as romantic
does it 11.
mince pies starting out as a large
oblong
mince pies were originally a mixture of
suet fruit
cinnamon cloves nutmeg and meat served
around christmas the mint pie evolved
throughout the victorian era with the
meat eventually being removed
12. mold wine created by the romans when
they'd heat wine to defend their bodies
against the cold winter mulled wines
spread across the empire and the regions
they traded with
its popularity continued throughout the
middle ages as we mixed heated wine with
spices
believing it would promote health and
prevent sickness and what better drink
to sit back and toast to this world of
culture
and history we've surrounded ourselves
with merry christmas
one and all thanks for watching if you
enjoyed that be sure to check out these
videos next and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification
each time we upload a new video